peru's new president pedro castillo has
been sworn in
in the capital lima these are live
pictures from the peruvian congress
castillo's swearing-in follows weeks of
uncertainty after a disputed election
result
castile took a surprise first place in
the first round of the presidential
election
in april then in june castile defeated
keiko fujimori by just
44 000 votes in the runoff
she alleged irregularities but the
electoral body rejected
her complaints castillo's left-wing
party wants to rewrite the constitution
and to address inequality several
foreign leaders are in lima for the
inauguration
okay so as we say live pictures there
from the peruvian congress in lima
as we continue watching these pictures
let's bring in mariana sanchez who is
standing by for us
also in lima and mariana this is a big
moment
for pedro castillo after a tricky few
weeks
after a tricky few weeks but there's a
lot of history behind
his uh persona his figure taking over
the government
kim because today uh marks the 200th
anniversary of the independence
from the colonialists the spanish
colonialists in peru
and throughout the uh republic
the elites have ruled throughout the
republic
and now for the first time it is a
farmer a person that comes
from one of the poorest the third
poorest district in peru
who is taking over the presidency we can
see
how humble his family is they have come
with their hats
his parents are people who don't know
how to read
and write his wife is a teacher
like pedro castillo and he has
won this this presidency
because of the clamor of the uh demands
of
millions and millions of peruvians who
wanted
who want change millions of peruvians
who feel
left behind and who have voted for
change the big question will be
will he be able to deliver on those
promises of change
uh especially now that he has really
begun with the left
foot here in congress where he is right
now uh taking his oath
uh he has promised that he will change
the constitution
something that he will not be able to do
uh without
congress and he has lost this first
battle in congress as he was unable to
form
a coalition that will favor him with
people from either the party he
represents or that
our parties that are allies with the
party he represents
it is an all opposition leadership in
congress that will not
accept and have said before that they
will not accept
a change in the constitution so there's
there are
there's not only a tough road ahead i
think there are going to be roadblocks
for this
new president to be able to govern kim
mariana it's interesting
isn't it because um pedro castillo is
now
kind of seen as the outsider but it was
his opponent keiko fujimori's
father um back in in 1990 he was then
seen
as the outsider now keiko is the insider
and castillo
is the as we say former teacher uh
son of peasant farmers he's the one
who's coming in from the outside
promising sweeping reforms
we're now just going to listen in as he
addresses the nation
bolivia chile ecuador
and his majesty the king of spain
vice presidents and chancellors
people
i start by greeting my
brothers the ancestors of this country
my brothers my brothers and teachers
and from the quechua the imaras
independence of peru i'm very proud to
be
here today
[Applause]
despite the fact that we commemorate
such a symbolic date
our history comes from
long before that
[Music]
we have five thousand
the destruction of the incas
the foundation of the republic that's
different
people that still exist today
the kingdom of spain allowed the riches
to be stolen
together with the cooperation of many of
us
[Music]
injustice
many of the indigenous people being
examinated
40 years later the independence of the
and we were second citizens
then came china and japan
helped us to become richer but without
it wasn't without painting
many people worked
in the um
as slaves and violence
[Music]
peasants and uncountable peruvians
continued
living as slaves
all adults could express their votes
thanks to the popular vote
and this time a government for the
people
has um is here
to to rule
for the people and by the people
a person who like many of the peruvians
is from the suppressed classes
it's the first time that a popular party
formed in the interior of the country
uh are here democratically
that i am also a country a son of this
country
and due to the sweat of my ancestors i'm
here
and due to the opportunity my parents
gave me
i too loved
[Music]
who studied in a school in the
countryside
and today i am here in order
this history
i want you to know that you have my word
i will not defraud you i
and we will not afford you
political lines is the
fight against the pandemic of kobe 19
maintain health and life our first
challenge is to fight the covert 19
which is hitting our country hard
and i don't want to forget on this
occasion
all the many peruvians who are no longer
with us
we
this would be a priority
the virus is not finished
but
peruvians first
ensure that all of the people are
vaccinated in the
in as little time as possible
in our country will be something
fundamental
a fundamental right which the government
will
which will be decentralized
we will
are created so that no family in peru
will not have um medical
[Applause]
in order to achieve that all of the
peruvians have helped
have this health service
we have to work throughout all levels of
the government
[Music]
for this i call on the regional
government leaders to
indicate where these hospitals will be
built
and we will start furthermore with the
construction
of the hospital in san juan
we have to end the century the
centralizing of these
people having to come to lima for
medical
treatment
it will be run by the men and women who
have castile
addressing congress having been sworn in
he started by thanking his fellow
teachers he of course was
a a country teacher himself made note of
the symbolism of the day
200 years since the independence of peru
said it was a government or would be a
government to rule the people
by the people uh he said this is the
first time the government has been led
by a peasant really made a lot about his
background
being a man of the people and said that
the fight against the pandemic
would be his first big challenge let's
bring in mariana sanchez
our correspondent who is joining us now
live from lima mariano what stood out to
you
from what pedro castillo had to say in
his maiden speech
well so far him as he's still speaking
it's very interesting he had
this very the very beginning of his
speech talking about
how peruvians for centuries have been
left behind
especially the peasants the farmer
peasants of peru
interestingly that he has talked about
spain and how
today is the anniversary of the bison
the bicentennial anniversary of the
independence from the colonialists from
spanish colonialists
and just yesterday he was having a
meeting with
the king of spain king felipe so it's
very interesting very symbolic if you
will that
he's uh the the the king of spain has
come
to salute this new president who comes
from
those who were left behind for centuries
in the country
that i think is very important for
castillo and also very important for
many
peruvians who see uh that it could be
their chance for
someone that comes from uh one of the
poorest districts in the country and
knows
uh the hurdles that people have to have
every single day to eat
mainly uh know and understand that he
will uh he will not forget them another
thing i think that's very
important and he was just mentioning the
this is that his
uh priority in his government
will be the pandemic it's very
interesting that he mentions this now
because he hasn't mentioned this
throughout
uh the campaign and in the past a few
weeks
since we were waiting for the
electoral uh commission to decide who
was
uh who had won the presidency now he has
um spoken about the pandemic and that
it will be the priority in his
government it is very important because
uh he has not only said that the
priority
number one number two number three has
to be the pandemic ass
and latest opinion paul says about what
peruvians
want from this new president and 75
percent
of peruvian say it is health he has
said also that he will take a lot of
care about
the health issues because when we
started the pandemic
as everyone else in the world the
peruvians
found out that there were for 33 million
peruvians only 140
icu beds for the whole country so that
is just a show
of how how fragile is
the healthcare system and how important
it is for
the forgotten for the poorest people of
peru to have
good healthcare so this this i think a
very two
important points that he has that he has
said at the beginning of his speech
marianna we we should remind our viewers
that um pedro castillo
won the election by raise a thin margin
so there's obviously a lot of people who
who haven't bought into his agenda
just remind our viewers of the social
and the economic context in peru
that brought castillo to power a man
with no previous government experience
that's right no previous government
experience
and mainly uh nearly unknown to most
peruvians although
he had been a member of a
center-right-wing party
a few years ago the leader of uh of us
of a national
teacher strike four years ago he was
mainly unknown to everyone
so how was it possible that he has won
the presidency
it is because he went from one
town to another in a small little towns
in rural remote areas of
uh of peru telling people that he wanted
to bring change and that he wanted to
bring
uh as he said uh in his uh motto
no more poor peruvians in a rich country
so he has gone and that message has been
very important
and has made people who don't who didn't
know
anything about him to vote for him
because
also there was a huge anti-corruption
vote in the country more than 50 percent
of peruvians
did not want to vote for keiko fujimori
uh her of his opponent his rival in this
presidency
she had lost two times for the same
reasons
with nearly the same margin of votes
uh 42 000 votes in the last election and
44 000 votes in this election
uh so there was a there was a
combination of factors that
made pedro castillo win first because
keiko fujimori is highly unliked in many
uh among many in the country and then
because castillo had this
this uh message of change of a new
constitution
which he probably won't be able to do or
or deliver but that's what people think
that people think that if
the constitution is changed they their
lives will
will change that laws will help them
have a a better prospect of a future
so uh so this is how pedro castillo from
coming from uh from from being
nearly unknown has won the presidency
all right thank you very much for that
mariana sanchez there live for us
in lima